what is going on everybody welcome to
the 10th Python with PI QT video series
tutorial in this video what we're going
to be talking about is adding a
drop-down menu but also or a drop down
button rather and also changing the
style of our window so that's actually
what our drop down will be it'll be
about the style of the window and users
will be able to choose different styles
for their window so let's go ahead and
just jump right in so we're going to add
the style this button will do it to home
we could put it in the in it this one it
would make a little sense maybe to put
in the in it but since this is a button
like if you're gonna have something that
changed the style you probably have it
in the main menu but I want to show you
a drop-down menu or a drop-down button
you call it menu if I was showing you
drop-down menu we put in the main menu I
want to show you drop-down button so I'm
gonna put it in home because that makes
the most sense but really if you're
going to change style you put in the
main menu and you'd have it up here but
it's a tutorial I'm trying to teach a
drop down my button shoot killing two
birds one stone so coming down here
we're just gonna add some more stuff and
we're gonna say self dot style choice no
choice equals cutie GUI
dot Q label now we haven't actually been
shown labels yet but here you go and
first we'll start with just windows and
actually I believe mine will be Windows
I'm on Windows 7 but I think the default
is actually Windows Vista you can put
whatever you want in here it does not
really matter you well show you actually
how you can find out what you're using
this will pass self so to find out
exactly what the default style is what
you can do is you can just will just
print it out print self dot style empty
parms object name camelcase that object
name and that'll tell you the style
you're currently using I'm almost
positive mine actually uses Windows
Vista even though you're on I'm on
Windows 7 now now that we've done that
we're going to create what's called a
the Q combo box both the combo box means
a drop-down button so anyway
bow box equals cutie GUI Q combo box
self then we're going to say combo box
dot add item and now we're going to add
all of the various items now there's us
there should be about six maybe some
more some less depending on what
operating system you're on but add these
if they don't exist
it won't like crash or it shouldn't at
least it didn't for me it just won't
change your style so you have some
choices there's motif and then there is
regular windows then there will be CDE
and then there is plastique and then
you've got clean looks actually snot
camel cased clean looks like that and
then Windows Vista I'm kind of a fan of
the clean looks but whatever so now that
you've got that added what we want to go
ahead and do is let's move our combo box
so we're going to say combo box dot move
we're going to move it to fifty to fifty
that should be good self dot and then
we're gonna say we're did style choice
right self dot style choice dot move
we'll move it to fifty one fifty and
then we're going to say combo box dot
activated so this would be like the
default and it also it'll display what's
activated so we'll say string dot
Connect and then we'll connect to self
dot this I'll throw me for a loop will
be fine actually style underscore choice
like that so once we've done that we're
going to come down here and we need to
define our method of style choice so
this is all the GUI aspect stuff so the
combo box placing it and showing the
current value other than that what we
need to do now is create the method
which is actually going to do something
with the choice so define
style choice whoops and we need to pass
self then what do we want to do what
we're going to say self dot style choice
diet set text to text so let me go back
up here right so this will set our text
so itself that style choice is just the
label that is saying what it is and then
the button should also say it as well
but we're just going to show labels
really quick to see self that's where m
is no choice so if that style choice set
text text and then we're going to say
qtg uiq
application dot set style and we're
going to set the style to Qt GUI dot Q s
style factory effect or e dot create
text okay so what this does is it it
just sets the style of your GUI
to whatever there's certain types of q
style factories and those these are the
types here the major types but again you
might have something like you might have
like macintosh right if you're running a
Macintosh you have that style and it's
probably your default but otherwise you
generally everyone will have at least
not Windows Vista but everyone should
have these for sure anyway that should
be it unless I messed up in because we
call it a lot of things style choice
here so it's really possible to screw
something up let's run it and find out
so here is our our choice Windows Vista
right now motif is the one that's
selected we need it we should probably
move that up but anyway let's click on
motif ah there we go
text so okay so obviously let's go
text let's close this self-styled choice
obviously needs the text parameter try
one more time there we go okay so you
can see here when I clicked Windows that
change we can do the download and you
can see that's a little different you
can check the boxes here you can see
that's a little different and even like
moving this thing around you can see
that things are just it's just acting
quite a bit different got windows CDE is
like an old-school kind of look very
basic and then you've got things like
plastique plastiques pretty cool I like
that plastic might be the one I was
thinking of actually that I prefer and
then clean looks
yeah likely looks do they're kind of
close I suppose and anyway and you can
move these around so you can kind of
decide which you like better
as far as all these variations so you
personally can kind of come through and
you can change the default style so
these DS Styles should go with use but
like like plastic motif CDE and clean
looks these are all possible to move
cross platforms so if you wanted it to
look like this all the time then you
would use plastique you would just need
to reset that so it doesn't use the
person's default style otherwise
everything else pretty much remains the
same all the code remains the same and
stuff like that but there's like a lot
of little minor changes
I think things look a little better with
plastique you know I just can't tend to
like it but plastique or clean looks are
probably the best but I like this one a
lot especially because it has it adds a
scroll bar when things are a little too
small as opposed to clean looks which
didn't it's just like stuffed ml in
there that's funny
anyway that's that if you guys have any
questions or comments up to this point
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time